- Guten Morgen, Herr Afarsiou,
ich grüße Sie.
- Guten Morgen, Hallo Frau Hombach,
Ich hab heute eine Auszubildende dabei.
Das ist die Patrycja.
- Guten Morgen.
- Morgen, Petra Hombach.
Grüße Sie, kommen Sie rein.
- Danke.
- Ja, der Papa wartet schon sehnlichst.
- Guten Morgen.
Na, gut geschlafen?
- Sieht man doch.
- Ja.
Ich habe heute die Patrycja dabei,
das ist die neue Auszubildende.
- Guten Morgen.
Ich heiße Patrycja.
Herr Hombach, wir würden uns
gerade mal vorbereiten,
und dann würden wir zu Ihnen kommen
und uns um Sie kümmern, ja?
Dann fangen wir direkt mal damit an,
die Beine zu waschen. Okay?
- Ja, okay.
- Gut, das ist die Patientenakte.
Hier vorne hast du immer das Stammblatt,
dann kannst du einfach
die Stammdaten sehen,
dann hast du die Diagnosen,
die ja für uns relevant sind.
Er hat zum Beispiel jetzt hier Diabetes
Mellitus, der insulinpflichtig ist,
und das müssen wir
immer beachten nachher.
Du hast hier einmal die Leistungskarte,
da kannst du sehen,
was wir genau machen.
Heute haben wir den 14., da sind wir
mit der kleinen Pflege dran,
deswegen machen wir
die Beine im Bett, ne?
Genau. Hier hast du
dann den Pflegebericht,
damit du dann noch mal gucken kannst,
ob irgendwas Besonderes war.
Genau. Dann desinfizieren
wir uns einmal die Hände.
Dann gehen wir das
einmal zusammen durch.
So, die Patrycja wird jetzt
einmal die Beine waschen, ja?
Ich werde da ein bisschen
drauf gucken, ne?
Und schauen, ob alles so
weit okay ist, ne?
Und ob wir was verbessern können.
Ja?
- Herr Hombach, möchten Sie
Seife im Wasser haben?
- Bitte?
- Möchten Sie Seife im Wasser haben?
- Ja.
- Okay, das steht schon
alles da vorne bereit.
Einen guten Schuss! Genau!
Das reicht schon völlig aus.
Wichtig ist, den Schritt immer
dem Patienten zu erklären, ne?
Genau, was du eigentlich tust,
dass du das rechte Bein anhebst,
damit er sich nicht erschreckt
und ... genau.
- Ich hebe jetzt erst mal Ihr rechtes
Bein und ich fange mit dem Waschen an.
- Genau, wichtig ist immer:
Gegen die Haarrichtung gerade morgens,
weil wir damit den Patienten aktivieren.
Abends würden wir zum Beispiel
mit der Haarrichtung waschen, ja?
Ja, wir würden als Nächstes
die Blutzuckermessung machen,
um zu gucken, wie der Blutzucker ist,
und entsprechend sein Insulin spritzen,
damit er dann frühstücken kann.
Herr Hombach, ich würde gern einmal
den Blutzucker bei Ihnen messen, ja?
Da dürfen Sie mir einmal
eine Hand zur Verfügung stellen.
Genau, dann nehmen wir uns den hier.
Du hast hier einmal den Blutzuckerstick.
Du würdest hier einmal quasi ziehen,
bis es einrastet.
Dann hast du hier den Punkt,
wo du draufdrücken kannst,
und dann springt eine Nadel raus.
Dann nimmst du den ersten Tropfen
weg, das ist immer ganz wichtig.
Und dann hast du hier das Gerät,
wo du das Blut aufträgst.
Du siehst hier die Markierung,
hier kommt der Tropfen Blut drauf
– zack – und dann rechnet das Gerät
dir quasi den Blutzuckergehalt aus.
Wir haben jetzt 160,
das ist völlig in Ordnung.
Und dann würden wir nachher
das Insulin entsprechend [verabreichen].
So, Herr Hombach,
160 ist der Blutzucker,
das ist in Ordnung.
- Ja ja, das weiß ich.
Dann gucken wir gleich mal wegen
dem Insulin, wie viel Sie dann kriegen, ja?